all right guys i am so excited for this
video that i'm doing this
completely unscripted i just have my
phone right here and i have read it
open because there's something massive
that just happened
i'm gonna tell you in just a second as
you guys know next week on tuesday
apple is hosting their september event
and a lot of the people on youtube are
saying that the iphone 12
is not getting announced next week but
this guy says that it actually
might happen his name is apple cedar on
reddit it's apple cedar 2020
and he is saying that he is the main
source for all the apple glass and
folding iphone leaks
this year and he says that the next
event on tuesday is going to have a huge
focus on ar
and some massive announcements inbound
so let's get
right into this video but first be sure
and check out our
apple product mask down below perhaps
the biggest thing
that apple cedar revealed on this reddit
post is that
this year there are a lot of conflicting
leaks and rumors
and that's because he says that apple
actually has
a dedicated team that puts out
conflicting leaks and rumors on purpose
so that's why john prosser was wrong
because apple is actually putting those
fake leaks out there
so without further ado let's get right
into this so apple cedar is saying that
he would provide
any kind of proof required by the mods
to keep this post on here and
according to one of the mods he says
that the original poster submitted some
proof
including some convos to various
reporters
so they are saying that he could
actually be legit and
based on what he's saying here it's
incredible one person
asked if we're getting 120 hertz to see
on the iphone he says
yes only on the 12 pro max
and apparently right here he's saying
it's because on the 12
pro the battery life would go below
iphone 10 standard so they chose only to
put it on
the max model as far as the shipping
date for the iphone 12 pro max he is
saying the end of october
here's another interesting thing about
the first apple silicon mac to be
released
he says that the first one is actually a
14
inch macbook pro 14 inch not 13 inch
like
all of the leaks were saying another
user asked about the 12 inch macbook and
he's saying yes
it's gonna come out but not at next
week's event
somebody asked about the 14 inch and he
says next week
for the 14 inch which is incredible
somebody asked how he gets his leaks and
he says that there are apple engineers
that love to talk about
their breakthroughs and that a lot of
them are respecting the ndas and the
contracts but
some of them are chaotic individuals so
that's where he gets his leaks from
now as far as the pricing for the new 14
inch macbook pro that's gonna get
released
he's saying that the price is gonna stay
the same as it is with current intel max
so somebody naturally said hey you're
betting against german
and prosser and he's saying that ar is
the big focus for this event
and either they don't announce iphones
and they announced the glasses and new
apple silicon macbook
and imac which is surprising or they are
going to announce the new iphones with
lighter sensors
and ar enhancements he says his money is
on the iphone
next week on tuesday as far as the
webcams on the macbook pros and
the imac he's saying that all of them
are getting a 1080p
camera finally he's saying that we
should look forward to ar improvements
but there's gonna be a big focus
on the folding iphone coming in the
future with a multitasking overhaul
which means you'll be able to use
safari two pages on one side notes on
one side so
lots of multitasking improvements he's
saying that handoff will gain
a lot of capability in the future and he
also says that
there's going to be a gaming console
slash apple tv
hybrid coming up i don't know if you've
heard about project
titan but basically apple is building
their own apple car
he is saying that project titan is
actually
an operating system by itself not an
actual car so apple is going to make a
car os
and they're going to sell that and have
it on different cars
different car manufacturers just like
they do with carplay now somebody asked
why game developers are gonna put aaa
games on apple silicon for example the
macs and the ipads
he's saying the value proposition for
developers is
build your game once and you have access
to any user
on any apple device and that arcade is
gonna help with that
somebody asked about apple glasses and
he's saying that they're gonna look like
a regular pair of glasses
with a slightly bulky frame here's
another detail
he says that you won't be looking at the
glass itself the displayed items will
hang in the air
in front of your face and as far as the
airpods studio over ear headphones he's
saying that he heard it's coming
next year but he's not 100 sure now i
know a lot of you guys were asking about
a hybrid ios and mac os device
basically meaning that mac os with a
touch screen
he says no hybrid device the push will
be for handoff and multitasking
it's really amazing actually because
being able to hand off any app between
devices
so you're going to be able to snap your
iphone shut and it's going to open up on
your imac or your macbook
exactly where you left off back to the
glasses he's saying that the iphone is
going to process everything
the glasses will just display the info
so that's how they're gonna be
just slightly more thick than regular
glasses as far as an imac getting face
id
he says it's in the works yes will we
see the light of day he
is not sure as far as the apple air tags
he's saying that there is no imminent
release
so it might not come next week but he's
saying he thinks
they're going to come with the apple
glasses which might come next year
but the bigger news is that find my app
is going to be gaining ar capability
augmented reality so you're going to
open your find my app you're going to
scan your room
and you're going to see your air tags
under your bed
you're going to see it under your
blanket behind something behind
furniture
that is just insane that's incredibly
innovative
on the apple watch series 6 the new
display is getting better
and has slimmer bezels and apart from
sleep tracking and oxygen monitoring
not much is changing feature-wise are
they releasing the ipad air 4 and will
it look like the leaks suggest
yes now talking about gaming now talking
about gaming on apple silicon he's
saying that with apple the target is
apple arcade and apple silicon
silicon will enable access to the entire
apple ecosystem
in one go arcade will evolve into a
better service with triple a titles in
the future
once silicon has grounded itself in the
max
he's saying that apple's focus on gaming
is more of making the ecosystem the
console
the silicon team is working really hard
to make mac gaming a thing
here's something very interesting he's
saying that pro motion 120hz technology
may come on the macbooks the imax he's
not sure
and as far as apple working on a
foldable iphone he's saying that there
will not be a folding screen
he's saying that you don't need a
folding screen to make a compelling
foldable device
so that means two separate displays with
a foldable iphone
no folding screen will there be lte
cellular service
in the macbook pros he is saying yes
that's what the intel team that apple
acquired recently within the last few
months
are working on no idea if it'll be
released but it's there
somebody asked if the 14 inch macbook
pro completely replaces the intel
13-inch
he is saying that they are going to live
together for the transition period
but the 13-inch will eventually go so it
looks like you're going to be able to
buy a 13-inch intel model
or you can choose the 14-inch apple
silicon and somebody asked will there be
an intel 14 inch
he says no why would you put an intel
chip into your newly redesigned 14 inch
macbook pro so
basically apple is phasing that out
somebody also asked about a new more
affordable apple display being in the
works
he says no the display stays pro for now
here is a big one i know a lot of you
guys are asking about the ipad pro
getting released one more time this year
he says no more updates to ipad pro
this year that is very big news now as
far as the rumored under display
fingerprint sensor for the ipad air 4 or
other devices
he says in display not happening now as
far as the leaks of the fingerprint
sensor being built into the power button
he says that the prototype was there but
it made the power button look a bit too
fat
and ergonomically it didn't really work
so they scrapped it so does that mean
it's getting face id
he says no no face id as far as he knows
he says that the home button is going to
stay intact
but it's going to have slimmer bezels
now back to the iphone 12 he's saying
that reverse wireless charging
is a no and pencil support is unlikely
as well he's also saying that the new
iphones are getting smaller bezels
finally and he says that the notch is
actually going to stay the same
but it's going to look smaller because
the display size is getting bigger at
least on the 12 pro max
back to the macbook pro he's saying that
slimmer bezels are happening on the 14
inch
with no face id this year now this is
some great news
the 12-inch macbook and the 16-inch
macbook pro with apple silicon
he says are coming in the spring next
year
and not the fall like some of us were
thinking so when asked about the imac
pro update
he says next year at wwdc right here
somebody mentioned that ming chi kuo was
saying that it's going to be a 13 inch
but he says he is sure that the 14 inch
is coming
next week not so sure about the imac
somebody asked about apple silicon
on the mac pro how's it gonna work well
he says that the gpus on the ipad
are already pretty good and that this
time this transition
apple has a huge point to prove that
they didn't have last time
and he says the performance will be at
the very least
comparable to the current intel mac pro
as far as the future of iphones he says
the iphone does not need usbc
anything the iphone requires lightning
already does so guys
no usbc on the iphone he says the future
of the iphone is
completely wireless no ports in the
future now here's something interesting
about apple silicon max he's saying that
windows
for arm support is coming in the future
for apple silicon max now i know some of
you guys really want a touch screen
on your mac he says that they were
scrapped in favor of the new ipad pro
with his keyboard somebody asked about
the pricing for the new ipad air he says
yes it's gonna start at the same
499 dollars with the new design based on
what he's saying right here i was
completely wrong in saying that apple is
making a huge push for gaming
in 2020. he says all of that is starting
next year with apple arcade and its
big push for gaming he says that he saw
a prototype apple tv 4k
that had a mac chip that was being
developed specifically
for gaming which is incredible now i
know some of you guys are talking about
apple acquiring peloton and their gym
equipment
he says no there is no interest in
peloton
apple health is focused on the user
monitoring
their health some of you guys really
want the glowing apple logo to come back
to the macbook he says no it's not
important
don't count on that another person asked
about the 24 inch imac replacing the
imac 21.5 inch
he says yes the 21 and a half is going
away but i haven't heard that it'll be
announced next week
so i doubt it will the ipad air get a
120hz pro motion display
he says 60hz for the ipad air this is
very interesting somebody asked about
the specs of the 14 inch macbook pro
that we should expect next week
he's saying that it's going to be the
m14 processor
not a14 m14 eight gigs of ddr4 ram
512 gigs of ssd four usb
4 ports apparently here's an absolutely
huge leak
that a lot of you guys are asking are
they going to refresh the 16-inch
macbook pro this year
with the newer intel chip no the 16-inch
is staying the same
until next year so if you guys are
waiting on that you can go ahead and
order using the links below
back to the 14 inch macbook pro he says
it's going to start shipping the end of
september
or early october now here's some
interesting info on the apple silicon
max they're going to have
m series processors different tiers will
exist
but not like intel's they're more based
on what features are actually on the
chip
the pro chips will have dedicated
engines or hardware accelerators for
specific tasks
while something like the 12-inch macbook
will get a more simple processor
for everyday users is the midnight blue
iphone a thing
yes and it's gorgeous how close is apple
to releasing a portless iphone
two years out he says will the apple
watch ever have blood glucose monitoring
yes will the iphone 12 pro mac support
the apple pencil
no pencil support is only for the ipad
now here's something funny he says that
the note 20 by samsung
was laughed at inside apple when it was
launched
the iphone will definitely be a lot
faster offer more longevity
more practical features etc the note 20
is just a numbers game
so there you guys have it that was a
bunch of exclusive leaks on reddit
by appleseeder2020 and it looks like we
might actually see the iphone 12 getting
announced next week
as well as the 14 inch macbook pro which
is just totally different from
everything else we've been hearing now
that would be amazing and as far as
his leaks and how confident we are in
them somebody said that
what if you're wrong he says we can all
come back here and laugh at the guy who
thought he had it all figured out
and he will join in himself so it seems
like this guy is very confident in what
he's saying
and based on the evidence he provided to
the mods he might actually be legit so
that's very exciting and this is totally
different
than everything else the other leakers
were saying like john prosser maybe mark
german
because he says that apple has an
exclusive team they actually have a team
that releases fake leaks just to confuse
everybody so that is a big shocker that
i was not expecting so
if you guys are excited for the apple
event next week definitely
click the circle above to subscribe and
check out our apple product merch like
our new mask
down below thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next video